[Heda Kovaly] My father's name was Irving Bloch,
my mother was Marta,
and I had a brother, Georg.
Both my grandparents were farmers,
which was quite unusual for a Jewish family.
Both of my grandparents had farms
and my parents grew up there.
I remember my grandmother very well.
She was gorgeous—white hair, very lovely.
And she was, um, killed when she was
86 years old by the Germans.
There was, um, very little food,
the work was dreadfully hard,
and it was completely closed.
It was so claustrophobic and there was
absolutely not enough food.
For me, Lodz was especially horrible
because of the children.
They cried, and cried,
and then they stopped crying one day.
They executed—
I don't know how many people,
because I never had the courage to go and look.
Becau—they let them hang
on the square for several days.
And my mother went there,
because she said someone
has to pray for them.
From time to time, the Germans came
and they took people away.
The Germans went from one place to the other.
And then they let us go in the street.
And there was this—
always this officer—
a German officer—
who
said this person go this way,
and this person goes back.
And they took all the
old people,
and the children, and took them away.
We went out of the train.
And they—
right there, they started dividing women from men.
And I only could see my father's face.
And he said, “Take care of Mother.”
And that was all.
And I was—you know, I didn't see him walking away.
It was just such a crowd, you see?
And, um,
we walked, hand-in-hand, with my mother.
And there was Mengele.
And he showed my mother the right side.
And I wanted to go with her.
And there was a soldier, and
he threw me to the ground, and said, "You stay here.”
“Where are these people going?
What's going to happen to them?”
And he said, “Don't be hysterical.
And if you ask, you aren’t going to see them again.”
Very vividly, I can—I can see
pictures, like in a movie.
You know, I can see details,
but I have a—there is no connection.
And the last, um,
uh, night, um...
I don't think
I spoke to anybody the whole time
I was in Auschwitz.
I just lost all, uh,
capability of communicating with people.
And I sort of crawled aside.
And I thought, my mother.
I couldn't think about anything except
my mother.
Moje máma.
And I remember sitting on the ground
and hold up my hand and
there was this big, um—you know the dandelions?
And it came to me and it landed on my hand.
And I thought, my mother, she's here.
I thought maybe she just died that moment.